les français ont pris la navrante
habitude de raconter des histoires
belges qui font passer nos amis belges
pour parfaitement stupide sans voulu
enregistrer un peu les réactions à
bruxelles sur cette affaire
a maison tarisio raison à charlo la vie
du bon côté oui mais ils font passer les
belges pour des imbéciles ah c'est pas
comme si le français dit quelque chose
au psg pour seulement de répondre eh
bien pas seulement une telle qu'est ce
que vous en pensez de ce à quoi ça me
rend pas plus
du coup les belges sont si les camps les
engage dans les cauchemars
québec lui trace
sa route un belge a voulu essayé de
peindre au pistolet il ya eu dix morts
c'est inhumain c'est pourquoi les belges
se mettre à la fenêtre qu'il ya de
l'orage et des éclairs c'est pour être
sur la photo c'est intelligent trois
vols
vers chicago doivent tous leurs feux
d'artifice bah oui oui comment fait-on
pour couler un sous-marin belge il
suffit de frapper à la porte
c'est pas
ça drôle
quelles mains et l'afrique
les rendements des histoires sur les
flamands et je trouve que les français
comptent vraiment est belle et oui tu as
choisi c'est un doigt un choisissez un
doigt qui les choisit et mettez le doigt
sur un toit c'est la grave mélange tout
fait peut-être qu'elle sait c'est
toujours ce week-end un week-end à la
whey vous avez trouvé alors
pts que dernier par rappeler français
racontent des histoires sur les berges
non moi je trouve ça bien
ouais
ce qu'ils font passer un peu les belges
ans pour dent ben alors l'apache à
condom se désespère sur la france
vous connaissez une ba oui laquelle ac
est allé à paris oui et alors de grâce
aux essais mais il trouve être celui ci
oui et alors là la famille des verts un
coup de fil dans un journal pourquoi
alors y avait l'armoire à glace mais il
n'a pas fait de lumière parce qu'il y
avait des envies de parent est alors
l'autre foyer de jeter sa part la
fenêtre et lula mara glace patate c'est
tout à fait revenu dans sa figure sa
femme mais d'autres dont je croyais pas
les rues et d'essayer droite à paris z
à quoi reconnaît-on une échelle belge
sur les années baruya écris stock
vous savez pourquoi les femmes
françaises ont des petits seins avec des
gros bouts non parce que les françaises
ont une grande gueule depuis petit mais
vous n'êtes pas très contents a rien
dans les faux pas et quoi on travaille
on se voit comme des cons pour aller
dépenser tout le douzième mois chez vous
à vous et
vous êtes un jour vers des trucs comme
ça
[Musique]